looking for ideas about how to scale
your machine learning training and
prediction well you've come to the right
place
with over 500 sessions at next 2018 it's
understandable that you couldn't get to
them all so if you didn't see ml in
production architecting for scale then
stay tuned because here's the rewind
when it comes to machine learning
there's two ml and production ml both
are very important though different
types of problems to solve for and when
we say scale as it pertains to machine
learning it not only means the usual you
require additional servers but also
being able to scale up to more training
data or bigger models and not having
reduced availability and response time
when prediction load increases on the
training side of things you should
definitely be using the TF data API and
if you're using it in a distributed
system there are a couple of Handy
arguments to add to some of your method
calls that will dramatically improve the
speed with which you can read in data
and this becomes especially important
when it comes time to use accelerators
like GPUs and TP use one additional area
that may be worth exploring if you want
to have just a little more control of
your infrastructure is cube flow which
helps you run tensor flow on kubernetes
though it's not limited to just tensor
flow and this library it tries to
address some of the challenges around
composability Portability and
scalability that are faced when building
larger ml systems turning now to the
prediction side of things there are a
number of optimizations that are worth
exploring the graph transform tool and
TF Lite allow you to optimize your model
for serving speed and there is even a
guide for how to properly optimize the
batching of your prediction calls so
that's handy and finally check out
tensor RT a library that allows you to
take full advantage of the tensor chords
in Nvidia's V 100 GPU this library was
developed in conjunction with the tensor
flow team here at Google so when it
comes to scaling up machine learning
there's a lot of options to navigate and
choices the way so be sure to check out
full talk if you've got some ml scaling
challenges that you are working on
thanks for watching this cloud rewind
and if you liked the video give it a
thumbs up I'm included a link to the
full talk in the description below and
don't forget to subscribe for more great
content and I'll see you on the next
rewind
[Music]